one of the reasons I wrote my book in
fact was to help people understand that
ordinary people from neither of my
parents graduated from high school
my mother had four children by the time
she was 23 I was born in a town of 1,200
people in a state where we had more cows
than people and we loved it that way and
I made mistakes
certainly I'm a human and I talk about
them very openly in the book because I
want people to understand you can still
be normal you can party down you know
you can have it make mistakes and and
reflect on them so you don't do them
again and I hope that people if the ones
who read it really understand that
everybody who's received to be surprised
or any of the Nobel Prizes they're
normal human beings full of flaws and
wonder just like everybody else but if
you work with others on a common goal
you can help change the world for the
better